RUCHIKA SIKRI: My
name is Ruchika Sikri,
and I'm a G+ program manager.
We are delighted to have
Irene join us today.
She's an ex-Googler, and I
saw she was exchanging cards
and notes with a lot of people
already, so that's great.
I just wanted to do a
quick intro for Irene,
and then I plan to defer to
her to share her experiences
with mindfulness
and product design.
Irene is an operating partner
at Khosla Ventures, a VC
firm known to most of
us in Silicon Valley.
She works over there with
hundreds of startups,
and continues to make
great design happen.
Prior to Khosla Ventures, Irene
ran product design at Audacity,
and also led user experience
at Google for six years,
so no wonder many
of us know her.
Before that, Irene established
and led the user experience
group at Yahoo.
For eight years she was there.
And she began her career
as an interaction designer
at Netscape Communications.
Actually, my husband and
I, we worked there together
as a pair.
I know her from
back in those days.
Irene also teaches
yoga and meditation
at Avalon Art and Yoga Center,
one of Palo Alto's oldest yoga
studios.
She passionately believes
in the transformative power
of mindfulness practices
which have helped
defined how she approaches
life and design.
Without further ado,
I present to you
Irene Au, who will share with us
how cultivating focus, empathy,
and creativity can help
with better product design.
[APPLAUSE]
IRENE AU: Thanks for having me.
So I'm miked up
here for the video.
And I miked-- actually,
this is-- is this even on?
It is?
OK, so I'm miked up
here so you can hear me.
Actually, can you hear me even
if I don't have the microphone?
Here?
Yeah, OK.
I'm going to try
ditching this because I
have too many things in my hand.
Thanks so much for
coming to hear me speak.
It's really an honor and
a delight to be back here.
So as Ruchika mentioned, I was
a Googler from 2006 to 2012.
Here's a picture of me from
"Fast Company Magazine" when
they decided to feature a
couple of notable Googlers.
They dressed us up
with funny props.
And that's me with all the
Post-It notes, because I think
for all of the work
that we did here
and the US team continues
to do here at Google,
we probably are responsible
for a huge portion
of 3M's sales of Post-It notes.
My personal story,
it's somewhere along
the way in the midst
of all the-- I mean,
managing design at
Google, to be honest,
was not a very easy job.
And so somewhere along the way
while I was here at Google,
I realized how
unsustainable my wife was.
Like, work/life balance
meant that I was waking up
at 5:00 in the morning
to go to the gym,
and so then I could see
my kids in the morning.
And when I realized
that my hips were
so tight I couldn't on the floor
to play with my kids, that's
when I realized, well,
I should probably
commit to some kind
of stretching or yoga.
And I had been exposed to
yoga from an early age, when
I was about 16, even
though I was growing up
in South Carolina.
Very unusual.
So I had practiced on and off.
And yet, meditation had
eluded me for a long.
Time But it wasn't until I
combined my yoga and meditation
practice that I've
really realized
the transformative
benefits of the practice.
So I left Google in
2012 to focus on yoga
and started teaching regularly.
In fact, I first started
teaching here at Google.
And I did that like
every Wednesday at noon.
Some of you have
been in my classes.
And I love the opportunity
to combine my passions
and interests.
But what I found after
practicing regularly and then
joining Udacity was
that I experienced
some of the most creative
periods of my life.
And some of those stories
are really deep and personal,
and others are confidential too.
You'd ask these, I can't
really go into too much detail.
But I really believe in how
yoga and meditation have
made me a better designer,
and how it's really
contributed
tremendously to the way
I think about product design
and product development.
So that's what I'd like
to share with you today.
So mindfulness
plus design-- Yes?
TECHNICIAN: Can
you move that way?
IRENE AU: Move this way, OK.
All right, OK.
There's all this stuff
hanging from the ceiling here.
As Ruchika mentioned, I just
joined as an operating partner
at Khosla Ventures where I'm
working with startups now
on design, making design great.
I also teach yoga and
meditation at Avalon.
So this is like up a mirroring
of two passions and interests
of mine.
But they really intersect.
So for example, how many of you
have been in this situation?
Like, you're working
really hard on a problem.
Maybe you're trying to design a
clever solution to a hard user
problem.
And it seems like the
more you think about it,
the more the
solution is elusive.
And the more you reach for it,
the harder it is to attain.
So maybe that's happened to you.
Product development requires an
abundance of analytic thinking.
We are constantly
immersed in technology.
So even those of us who
are not software developers
have to think logically,
think algorithmically,
so that we can design and
conceive technical solutions
to user problems.
And as designers, even designers
learn methods and practices
like task analysis and heuristic
evaluation, card sorting,
things like that.
We've turned the act of
design into a science.
And we run experiments
to gather data
to inform design decisions.
And so we've turned the act of
design so much into a science
that we've cast
innovation as a process,
and terms like
data driven design
have become part
of our vernacular.
But product design and product
development and computer
scientists, the best
computer scientists,
will also say that development
and design is both a science
and an art, and yet far
less time and energy
is spent on teaching people
how to be more creative.
We've kind of
mystified creativity.
And we see people as being
like creative geniuses,
naturally-born creative
geniuses, or not.
And it's possible that
some people are naturally
born more creative than others.
But more realistically,
we all lie along
some spectrum between analytic
thinking and creative thinking.
So the question is like
for us mere mortals,
how might we learn
the skills that we
need to be more creative
and more effective
at product design and
product development?
So for example, how
can we be more focused
so that we can deliver the
one or two key features that
would be most
useful to our users?
How can we cultivate empathy
and compassion for our users
for the people who are using the
products so that we can design
the products to be more usable?
And how can we be
more innovative
and bring more
inspiration and delight
to the people who are using the
products that we're creating?
So those are three
things I want to focus
on today-- focus,
empathy, and creativity.
Those are all skills
that can be learned.
And there are concrete
things that we can all
do to become better at that.
And that's what we're
going to talk about,
is how to cultivate focus,
empathy, and creativity
through mindfulness practices
like yoga and meditation.
So what is mindfuness?
Mindfulness is a way of paying
attention to and seeing clearly
what is happening in our lives.
That attention
paid is purposeful.
It's in the moment,
without judgment.
And it's about having the
time and space to tend
to whatever is in front of us in
spite of any distractions that
might be competing
for our attention
and any kind of
past history that
might shape how we think
and perceive the world.
And one of the best ways
to cultivate mindfulness
is through attention training.
And we train our attention
through meditation.
Now, meditation is a broad term.
It's like the word "sports."
Sports can refer to a variety
of things like tennis, swimming,
cycling.
Similarly, meditation can
refer to a lot of activities.
There are a lot of
ways to meditate.
But the simplest and most
widely form of meditation
is to sit and focus
on the breath.
The breath is the
foundation for meditation.
And this is because it's free
and it's easily accessible.
It's there when you need it.
And it calms the
nervous system down.
So just to demonstrate,
so let's try this now.
So come to a comfortable seat.
And find like some
kind of posture
that allows you to be relaxed
and alert at the same time.
One word that I like
to use is dignity.
So if you think
about what it means
to feel dignified
in your posture,
it's not like you're
erect and stiff.
You're relaxed,
but you're also on.
OK?
And you can choose
to close by the eyes,
or you can keep them open.
You can have than half
open, half closed.
And then bring the
awareness within.
Just rest the mind.
If you choose to
keep your eyes open,
you can gently
gaze at something,
softly gaze at something, maybe
18 inches in front of you.
And just pause for a moment.
And then shift into
focused attention
by bringing the
awareness to the breath.
OK, you could also choose any
other object of meditation.
Sometimes people focus
on a candle or a mandala.
You can notice the
rising and falling
of the breath in the body.
And in this form of
meditation, your awareness
is steady and focused.
So if the mind wanders,
just notice the thoughts
without judgment, and then
gently bring the awareness back
to the breath.
Take a few more breaths
in stillness here.
And then slowly open the eyes,
bring the awareness back.
OK.
Now, I don't know
about you, but I
find meditation to be incredibly
difficult, particularly
in this day and age when we
have so many things competing
for our attention.
We are constantly
distracted, and our minds
are notorious at wandering
from thought to thought.
So it is really hard
even just to string
a few moments of uninterrupted
thought together.
And for years I tried
meditation off and on,
hoping that it would give me
some refuge from the stress
that I experienced.
And I thought that meditation
was about relaxing the mind
and cleansing the
mind of all thoughts.
But I found that to
not be true for me.
Meditation is really hard work,
and it takes a lot of practice
to get there.
But that hard work is worth it.
We're are getting better insight
into how meditation affects
the brain thanks to
advances in FMRI technology.
So a study of people who
meditate versus people
who don't found that brain
areas linked with attention
and sensory processing are
thicker in people who meditate.
And it's not just a correlation.
They found that the longer
that people meditated,
the thicker those parts
of the brain can become.
So we can really change our
brains through mental training.
And even though focusing
the mind is hard work,
it doesn't take
long to experience
the benefits of meditation.
So just meditating for 20
minutes a day for four days
can result in
significant improvements
in cognitive skills.
But it's not just
cognitive skills
that improve with meditation.
So in 2009, Antoine
Lutz and his team
tested participants before
and after participating
in an intensive three-month
meditation retreat.
And they practiced mindfulness
meditation on a daily basis.
Meditators were found to
be significantly better
at selectively training their
attention compared to people
who were just
starting the practice.
And just earlier
this year, there
was a study published from
the University of Miami
that reported that students who
took a seven-week mindfulness
based training course showed
significant improvement
in attention and
diminished mind wandering
compared to a control group
that didn't participate in this.
And they had increased
mind wandering
over time and diminished
attention and focus over time.
So when we create this habit of
practicing focused attention,
it becomes easier with practice.
Focused attention
is like a muscle,
one that gets stronger
with exercise.
Just like core, when you
practice forearm plank, which
is one of my favorite
strengthening exercises to do.
So the more you do it,
the easier it becomes.
And it's this clarity of
mind, this focused attention,
that is paramount to the
active product development.
A cluttered mind leads to
cluttered UI and design.
And an unfocused mind leads
to a confused experience.
Focus refers to paying
attention to what
is most important and
meaningful in the moment,
but it's also an
act of letting go.
Simplifying and decluttering
are also mindfulness practices.
And there are ways to practice
living in the present moment.
In product development,
lack of focus
often stems from a
deeper issue around ego.
So for example,
maybe we don't want
to cut features
because we don't want
to disappoint early adopters
who want power and flexibility.
Or maybe we don't want to
give up potential revenue
opportunities, even though
it doesn't make sense
for the product
or for the users,
because we don't want to
leave money on the table.
Or maybe we want to add
functionality to a product
because it's
technically possible.
And in any of these cases,
it all comes back to ego.
So mindfulness
practices help people
let go of their ego
and deal with whatever
is getting in the way of
simplifying and decluttering.
And then simplification
then becomes
less of an act of
ruthless elimination
and more an act of
love and compassion
for the users who ultimately
benefit from the product.
Now let's talk about empathy.
Empathy, like focus, is crucial
for great product design.
In fact, many design leaders I
talk to-- including ones here
at Google-- will say
that the number one
skill that they look for when
interviewing potential people
to join their team is empathy.
It's one of the top things
they look for when hiring.
And yet empathic thinking is
increasingly difficult for us.
Our constant connection
to digital technology
skews us away from real face
to face human interaction,
to the point where we're not
communicating so much face
to face but more by computer
mediated communication.
And moreover, many of us
are designing and developing
technology for human use.
And we are inside these
companies like Google
where it's dominated by
analytic thinking, right?
It's run by engineers.
And this is where people
are rewarded and motivated
to think analytically.
Designers, for example, are
rewarded for their ability
to rationalize design
based on data and reason--
hence the term
"data-driven design."
And that's all very valuable.
But it turns out
that as we engage
in analytic thinking,
which most of us
are doing in the
workplace, we're
less able to engage in
empathetic thinking.
So Anthony Jack from
Case Western University
found that when people
think analytically,
when they think about the
technical details of how
something works, they are
less able to really get
inside someone's brain
and empathize with them.
And then conversely, the more
we try to relate to others
and really feel their
experience, the less able
we are to think analytically.
So there's a neurological
divide between these areas
of the brain.
And that represents
a cognitive tension
between these two
modes of understanding.
So what does this have to
do with product development?
Well, product
development, good design
requires both modes
of thinking, right?
It requires
technical excellence.
But that technical
excellence have
to be directed towards a
great user experience, which
takes empathetic imagination.
And as user experience
people, and those of us
who work in product
development, we
try to build empathy for our
users either in the field
or in the lab.
So we have lots of usability
labs throughout the campus.
We go out on field studies.
These endeavors are really
important and worthwhile.
But they're still
analytic endeavors.
We take notes, we
code the behaviors,
we synthesize what we've seen.
And then we analyze
what we've observed.
But true empathy goes
beyond observation.
It's about feeling their
experience in your bones.
Psychological testing
shows us that people
tend to be better at one mode
of thinking than the other.
So you may not be
surprised, for example,
to learn that women, on
average, tend to be stronger
at empathetic thinking, and men,
on average, tend to be stronger
at analytical thinking.
But it's not just a
gender difference.
Like even if you look just
at women or just at men,
there's still a
range of inclination
towards one mode or the other.
But we can train both networks.
A lot of recent work
suggests that we
can train our analytic, spatial,
visual abilities by playing
fast action violent video games.
So women, you might
be pleased to learn
that if you play violent,
fast action, violent video
games for two weeks,
you can catch up
to men in their average
visual spatial skills.
But playing violent,
fast action video games
was also found to
decrease empathy.
So training the network in
one direction comes at a cost.
We can also train the
network in another direction.
We can train the
empathetic network.
Much research has proven that
yoga and meditation boosts
one's empathy and
compassion for others.
So researchers at the University
of Rochester Medical Center
found that training doctors
in mindfulness meditation
practices resulted in doctors
being less judgmental,
both at home and at work.
And another study found
that people's ability
to recognize people's
subtle facial expressions
improved dramatically
after practicing yoga.
And this effect was
even more pronounced
among people who had a
regular yoga practice
and among people who practiced
a flow sequence for some reason.
Yay, vinyasa flow!
OK, so in addition to being
a meditative practice,
yoga boosts one's
empathy because
of the mind/body connection.
So we're all familiar with what
tension in the body feels like.
Like when you're
stressed out, maybe
feel tension in the shoulders
or your neck gets stiff.
So we understand that our mental
condition affects the body.
But now there's a
growing body of research
that suggests that it works in
the opposite direction as well.
The relationship
is bi-directional.
Changes in the body can
change one's motions,
mood, hormone and
gene expression.
For example, we smile
when we feel happy.
But we also feel happier
when we're forced to smile,
like when we hold a
pencil between our teeth.
And it turns out the
converse is true, too.
So Dr. Eric Finzi ran a
study where he injected Botox
into the frown muscles
in people's faces
so they were literally
paralyzed from frowning.
These were among people who
were diagnosed with depression.
And in this case,
27% of the patients
got better from depression
compared to a 7% improvement
rate in a control group that
wasn't treated with the Botox.
So paralyzing the face
and preventing people
from frowning literally
cured people from depression.
The relationship between
the mind and the body
is not just limited to the face.
So at Harvard University,
Amy Cuddy and her colleagues
have studied the
effect posture has
on hormone production
and gene expression.
And she has given one of
the most watched TED Talks
out there, so some of you may be
familiar with her work already.
So Cuddy and her team
put research participants
in different kind of postures
and measured their hormone
levels.
So some people were put in
high power poses-- so like,
legs apart, hands on the
hips, that sort of thing,
like gigantic movements
that take up a lot of space.
And then other people
were put in low power
more submissive poses,
like legs crossed,
arms crossed, people
shrinking within themselves.
And after just two minutes, they
found that testosterone levels
shot upwards amongst the people
who were in high power poses,
and cortisol levels
decreased among these people.
And then they gave
these people a chance
to play a gambling
game and found
that being in a high power
pose made them much more
aggressive later on.
So what she found was that our
non-verbal language governs
how we think and feel,
and that our bodies
can change our minds.
And so if you think about
this in the context of product
development, changing the body
and changing the postures,
the postures that we assume
during different phases
of product
development and design
can totally change
how we think, how
we approach the act of design.
So like in today's modern age,
we are doing a lot of this.
In fact, a lot of us are
doing this right now.
We are constantly in
a defensive posture.
And this defensive posture
reinforces our natural tendency
to protect ourselves,
especially our egos.
And this can lead to
tension in the body that
builds up and
inhibits our openness
to new ideas, new
people, new situations.
And so to counteract that,
we have to open up the body
and release the
tension that builds up.
The spaciousness that
we create in the bodies
helps create spaciousness
in the minds-- so
like an open body, an open mind.
Yoga poses that help
open up the shoulders
and the chest are
often referred to
by yoga teachers as chest
openers or heart openers.
In the same way that they
help create spaciousness
in the chest cavity, they
create spaciousness in the heart
and are thought to help people
deal with challenging situation
like difficult
relationships or relating
to other people
or new situations.
So let's try opening up
the body for a few moments.
So let's all stand
up for a moment.
OK.
And nothing too fancy.
I'm wearing a
dress, so we're not
going to go into
downward dog or anything.
But just take a deep breath in
and inhale, bring arms that in
and then grab the left
wrist with your right hand.
And then as you exhale,
lean over to your right.
So you guys are going to
be leaning over there.
And you can make your breath
long and smooth and steady.
And if you want to
exaggerate this opening
along the left side body, press
that left heel into the floor.
And at the same time,
lengthen the right side body.
And then come back to
center, change your grip,
and then go on the other
side on the exhale.
Press the right
heel into the floor.
And then inhale,
come back to center.
Now interlace your
hands behind your back.
So start with the collar
bones and widen them,
roll the shoulders
back, and squeeze
the tips of the shoulder
blades together.
OK, and then lift your
sternum up towards the sky.
Lengthen the tailbone
towards the heels.
Lift your chest, lift your gaze.
And then maybe move your hands
away from the sacrum just
to open up the chest and
counteract the rounding
that we do all day.
And then exhale, release.
Now you can sit back down again.
And one final thing,
you can take a twist.
So as you sit down, maybe
grab the back of your chair.
Or for those of you who
are sitting on these cubes,
grab onto the stool
or just anything
that gives you leverage.
Take a breath, inhale,
and then get tall.
And then exhale, give yourself
a little twist to the right.
And then inhale, come back
to the center, change sides.
Exhale, twist to the left.
And if catch anybody's eye,
you can give them a smile.
And inhale, come back to center.
Now didn't that feel good?
Yes.
OK, all right.
Now let's talk about creativity.
We can exploit the
mind/body connection
to help build empathy
toward others.
And in the same way, we can
use the mind/body connection
to improve our creativity.
So I want talk about
the psoas for a moment.
I talked about the
mind/body connection
as it relates to the
face, the neck, the chest
and the shoulders.
But there's also a
mind/body connection
as it relates to the hips.
The psoas muscle
is the only muscle
to connect the spinal
cord to the legs.
And it's responsible
for holding us upright.
It helps us lift our legs
in order to walk or run.
And a healthy functioning
psoas stabilizes the pelvis
and provides a protective
core for the abdominal organs.
And the psoas is
connected the diaphragm
through fascia, or
connective, tissue which
affects both our breath
and our fear reflex.
And that's because the
psoas is directly connected
to the reptilian brain.
It's the most
ancient interior part
of the brain stem
and spinal cord.
And our fast-paced modern
lifestyle constantly
triggers and
activates the psoas.
So the psoas is
constantly tight.
Because it's connected
to the reptilian brain,
we are ready to fight
or flight, like it's
ready to trigger you to curl
up into a protective ball
or to launch you into
action to run away
from that tiger
that threatens you.
And in this modern
day and age, we're
constantly contracting
the psoas because we're
sitting all day, either
behind the driving wheel
or behind the computer.
And it causes the
muscle to shorten.
When it's short, it can lead to
a whole host of painful issues,
painful situations, like
low back pain, sciatica,
disk problems, hip degeneration.
Sometimes people
believe it can relate
to menstrual
problems, infertility,
and digestive problems.
So a very critical muscle,
and a lot of people
have never heard of it.
And this situation
is exacerbated
by our modern lifestyle.
And we have
ill-defined chairs that
distort our posture,
high-heeled shoes that
lead us to distort
our posture as well.
And it just curtails
our natural movement
and further
constricts the psoas.
So why is this relevant?
Well, a relaxed psoas
is the body's mark
of play and creativity,
instead of a contracted psoas,
ready to run or fight.
The open release psoas is
ready to lengthen and dance.
This is called dancer's pose.
You can see how open
the psoas is here.
So a mobile, healthy psoas gives
us the benefits of mobility
and also the physical comfort
of just being in the world.
So it leads to a more
calm way of being.
Yoga teachers will
often anecdotally report
that people with more
open hips are naturally
more creative and playful.
And the physiology
of the body suggests
that there could be
something to that.
By releasing our
hips and hip flexors,
we release our stored anger
and negative emotions.
And by letting go of our
anger and negative emotions,
we free ourselves to become
more playful and creative.
So meditation also
affects creativity.
But how it affects
creativity depends
on what kind of
meditation you engage in.
So remember when
I said that there
are multiple forms
of meditation?
What we practiced
before is a form
of focused attention meditation.
There's another
form of meditation
called open
monitoring meditation.
And in focused
attention meditation,
this is a very common
practice in Hindu traditions.
Open monitoring
meditation is more
common in Vipassana practices.
And in this form
of meditation, you
practice monitoring your
experience from moment
to moment.
And you let your mind wander
without any kind of reaction.
So you're entering the world
with curiosity, acceptance
and openness, and without
reaction or judgment
or the need to hold on
or do anything about it.
So we're going to try that now.
So come to a comfortable seat.
Again, take a posture that
allows you to hold with dignity
or be relaxed and
alert at the same time.
And close the eyes for a
moment and direct your breath,
direct your attention to the
abdomen, maybe an inch or two
above the navel.
And find that point that
seems the clearest to you.
Just notice it in your
mind, you don't actually
have to look at it.
Notice how as you breathe
in, the abdomen expands.
And as you breathe
out, it contracts.
Notice the rising and the
falling of the breath.
And as the abdomen
rises and falls,
observe the motion
with your mind
from the beginning to the end.
Just keep watching the
rising and falling.
You don't have to do
anything or control anything.
You don't have to describe
them or judge them.
And then bring your attention
to whatever experience
or thought comes to your mind.
In this form of
meditation, your attention
is flexible and malleable.
It's kind of like paper
flowing in the wind,
or like a feather drifting off.
And anything that
comes to your mind
is fair game as a focal
point for meditation.
You can choose to
train the attention
on that thought or
that experience,
or you can allow your mind to
drift off and get carried off
to something else.
Slowly bring the awareness back.
Take a few more breaths here.
And then come back into the
room and open your eyes.
OK, so research done in
2012 in the Netherlands
at Leiden University compared
open monitoring meditation
with focused
attention meditation
and looked at those
effects on creativity.
And what they found was that
open monitoring meditation
helps foster people's
ability to think divergently.
And this is exactly what we want
to do in design brainstorms is
divergent thinking.
That's the ability to
generate a lot of ideas
in a period of time.
This is also the
kind of thing that we
do we design sprints or in
workshops that are often
hosted here at The Garage.
So we want to generate
as many ideas as possible
when we're brainstorming.
And open monitoring
meditation helps with that.
You can practice both
focused attention meditation
and open monitoring
meditation at the same time.
The simplest way to do this is
just to focus on the breath.
And then as the
mind wanders, you
notice the thoughts
without judgment,
and then gently bring the
attention back to the breath.
And in this way, it's very
similar to circuit training
at the gym, where you're
mixing in high intensity
cardio with resistance training
and alternating between them.
So this is a nice way to
cultivate the ability to focus
and the ability to be
creative and think divergently
at the same time.
Yoga starts, out for many
people, as a physical product,
and then naturally evolves
into the art of living well.
As negative habits,
thoughts, behaviors,
influences within
ourselves and outside start
to progressively
get dropped in favor
of healthier ways of thinking
in being in the world, yoga
becomes a way of life and
moving through the world.
It becomes not about what
we do, but how we do things.
And this is where the impact
of yoga and meditation
is the most profound and
is most transformative.
Mindfulness practices
help you let
go of fear-- fear
of being judged,
fear of trying new things.
When you let go of fear,
you can truly be present.
When you're present, you
are more able to fully enjoy
the experience of whatever
activity you're engaged in.
And being able to
enjoy the journey more
than the destination is
one of the best things
that you can do for
your creativity.
Stanford psychologist Philip
Zimbardo studied this effect
and demonstrated this
phenomenon through his research.
He studies what
happens to people
when they're engaged in creative
activities that are focused
on the final outcome as
opposed to just enjoying
the process of making.
And so in this study,
what he did was
he took Stanford
college students
and had them paint pictures
of a basket of flowers.
And in one condition,
he told them
that judges from
the art department
would evaluate the
quality of the paintings
based on different criteria.
And the other half
with told just
to focus on the
artistic process itself.
And after participants finished,
several graduate students
from the art department came
and evaluated the paintings
based on different criteria--
such as technical merit,
such as best uses of colors,
space, and layout, and then
also on creativity, such
as originality and novel
use of color and design.
You may not be
surprised to find out
that the people
focused on the present
were judged to be
the most creative.
And people in the
product condition,
the people who were focused
on the final outcome,
produced paintings with
the most technical merit.
And these findings
suggest that creativity
is fostered when people are
disposed towards the present,
and that technical
merit is cultivated
when people are focused
on the final outcome.
And here are a
few examples here.
So this painting
in the top left is
painted by somebody who is in
the product condition, focused
on the final outcome.
The paintings on the
bottom are painted
by people who are in
the process condition,
so they were told to just
enjoy the act of painting.
And this one in
the upper right was
painted by somebody who was told
to focus on the final outcome,
but self-describes
as somebody who
just enjoys the act of painting.
You can see he was a little
bit frustrated there.
So successful design
requires both creativity
and technical merit.
So we need both.
We need to be focused
on the final outcome,
and we need to just
enjoy the act of making.
And so as we engage in design
and product development,
it's important for
us to understand
what mindset we
should be in depending
on what phase of product
development we're in.
So when we're
ideating, it's crucial
that we let go of
judgment of ideas
so that we can free ourselves
to be more creative and playful
and generate a lot of ideas.
And then when our egos
are not put on the line,
we can then be more
playful and relaxed.
And when you're more
fully engaged in play,
you lose some of those
psychological barriers that
inhibit you from
generating your new ideas
or editing your thoughts.
And then knowing that the
mindset around product
orientation is crucial
when it comes to converging
and narrowing down the choices
and refining the product
and focusing on the details.
So concretely, what can
you do to prime your body
and your mind for
product development?
Well, nothing beats a regular
yoga and meditation practice.
So there's this [INAUDIBLE]
that you should be practicing
for 20 minutes a day--
unless you really need it,
then you need to
practice for an hour,
and if you can't
find the 20 minutes.
But more seriously,
like everybody
can find five minutes.
So I would encourage you, if you
don't have a regular practice,
just to start there
and find five minutes.
And then maybe over
time, that five minutes
can grow to ten minutes
and maybe twenty minutes,
just to sit with yourself.
And in terms of yoga,
practicing for at least an hour
per day, three days
a week, can lead
to significant improvements
in opening up the body.
But if you don't have time
for regular yoga practice,
here are some simple
things that you
can do to prime the
body for design.
When you're seeking
inspiration-- such
as you're in the
ideation process,
maybe you're trying to
generate, brainstorm,
and come up with a lot of ideas.
Chest and shoulder openers
and side body stretches
help open up the
body to new ideas,
new thoughts, new people,
help prime the body
for that openness that
we talked about before.
Simple poses like
supported fish pose--
this is a nice, passive pose--
or standing crescent pose help
create that spaciousness
in the body.
And then stretching
also prepares the body
for the design process
for design brainstorm.
So in addition to opening up
the shoulders and the chest,
opening up the hip
flexors with pigeon
or opening up the psoas
with a low crescent
lunch or a cobbler's pose helps
facilitate divergent thinking,
and it open the psoas, allows
for playfulness and creativity.
And then when you're ready to
execute and refine your design
ideas, focused
attention meditation
helps improve your ability to
focus, simplify, and declutter.
Forward folds turn you
inwards so that you
can find the introspection
that you need to synthesize.
Now, I know that this
idea of doing yoga at work
might be discomforting at first.
I've actually led hackathons
at startups and school board
meetings, like strategic
outsides, with some stretches.
And even though people feel this
is a little awkward and weird,
it actually-- people are so
grateful for that opportunity
to breathe and to
open up the body
before they go into
these brainstorms.
It just gets them
into the right mindset
around playfulness
and creativity.
So it might seem awkward.
Out of any company
in the world, this
is the place to do it,
because the whole [INAUDIBLE]
and all the support
we have here.
So it may not be as
awkward as you think.
But even outside of
Google, companies
are really embracing this.
General Mills, Aetna are
embracing yoga and meditation
at work.
Twitter cofounder Evan
Williams meditates regularly,
and now at his new
startup, Medium,
they sponsor people to
go on yoga retreats.
Justin Rosenstein, who used
to work here at Google, then
at Facebook, and now is
the co-founder of Asana,
sees mindfulness not just
as a way to improve oneself
but uses these as principles
to run his company
and informs how they
develop products.
So the principles of
yoga and brain science
are now converging.
And together, they can create
a blueprint for transformation.
With meditation
and yoga, you can
change your brain and how
you move into the world.
And that, in turn,
affects how you
approach product
development and design.
Personally, I've
experienced some
of the most creative
periods of my career
since adopting a regular
yoga and meditation practice.
And while I haven't
done concrete AB studies
on anybody or myself, I
can only have my experience
to share, which I feel
so passionately about.
So back to that scenario that we
talked about at the beginning,
where you're working
on a hard problem.
Sometimes when you
just relax and let
your mind wander
and release yourself
from working on that solution,
some insight might reach us.
And the solution
then becomes obvious.
And we can train our minds
to be better at this.
Focus, empathy,
and creativity-- we
all have the capacity
to strengthen
these skills and the
means to do that better.
Mindfulness practices
are techniques
that allow us to
dive within the mind
and transcend the intellect
so that we can experience
that deepest level within
ourselves, which we can bring
forward to the work that we do.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Any questions?
Here's my contact
information if any of you
want to contact me later.
OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
where you're talking,
but I hadn't heard
that before about--
you had that one scientist or
whatever who said that when
people are really analytic--
IRENE AU: Yeah,
Anthony Jack, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Did I
understand you correctly,
it's like if you focus
on developing one,
it actually weakens the other?
IRENE AU: Yes, it
weakens the other.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's sad.
IRENE AU: Yeah.
It also made
tremendous sense to me
in the kind of as I reflected
on my own experience
at Google, because we're a
very highly analytical culture.
And it's why I'm so grateful
for programs like SIY,
because they help strengthen
people's emotional intelligence
and ability to empathize
and relate to other people.
These were similar
initiatives that we advocated
for within the user
experience team
too, through user research,
and helping people.
Many of you who
joined Google might
have gone through the
new hire program where
we had life of a user.
I don't know if we still run
that now, but when I was here
we have life of a
user, where we tried
to put people in the
mindset of user's shoes
and help them use that as
stimulus to inform and inspire
product ideas and innovation.
And so it's very much akin
to what SIY is trying to do.
It's trying to boost empathic
thinking and imagination,
because when we naturally
think analytically here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that
muscle in our hip that--
IRENE AU: Yeah, the psoas.
It's spelled P-S-O-A-S.
AUDIENCE: Do you have where
we can learn more about that?
That's so interesting.
IRENE AU: There is a
whole book on the psoas.
And the name of the author
escapes me, but I will--
AUDIENCE: Liz Koch.
IRENE AU: What's that?
AUDIENCE: I think it's Liz Koch.
IRENE AU: Yes, that's it.
Liz Koch.
AUDIENCE: K-O-C-H.
IRENE AU: Yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: She also does
workshops on the psoas
periodically in the area, so
you could look her up too.
IRENE AU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
it's a great read.
IRENE AU: Yeah, an
entire book on the psoas.
AUDIENCE: It's worth it.
IRENE AU: It's funny, I learned
about this phenomenon called
gluteal amnesia also, in
which some people have trouble
like folding forward
and touching their toes.
And a lot of that is
related to tightness
in the lower back,
which is related
to tightness in the hip flexors.
And some of us, over
time, lose connection
to the gluteal muscles
and the hamstrings which
fire in order to fold forward.
And there are a lot of exercises
that you can do in order
to retrain yourself and get
those muscles to fire again.
But that alone is often
responsible for a lot
of low back pain that
people experience.
And especially
amongst the community,
because we are sitting
at our computers so much.
AUDIENCE: Right.
I was just describing my dad
and, lower back pain in life.
Super, super, show me
your resources and data
on back pain [INAUDIBLE].
That's a good start.
IRENE AU: Right, yeah.
It's hard to do AB studies
though, so a lot of it
is anecdotal.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for that.
I wonder how much of it
is to do with our body's
system, that generally
although yoga is becoming sort
of trendy and interesting
now, our value is still
placed so strongly on
the analytical side,
so that if you introduce
mindfulness and all
these things, people might
still discount it as, that's
just a little bit weird,
you know, hippy or whatever,
especially like at Google.
How do you deal with
that, and how do you
introduce it in your startups?
I'm really curious
on your [INAUDIBLE].
Do you they just trust
you because you're
their design partner?
IRENE AU: I'm not
doing this with any
of the companies
in the portfolio,
so the whole yoga thing
is a separate thing.
I just started last week.
Yeah, and both modes of
thinking are important.
And I don't mean to
disparage data-driven design,
because it is
important to use data
to inform design decisions.
But it's also important
to go into this other mode
of thinking, like the
creative mind is not
the analytical mind.
And I hope that people
understand that more
and appreciate the different
mindsets that you can engage in
so that you go into the
appropriate frame of mind
during different parts of
product development and design.
It was quite a revelation to
me as we developed this design
sprint methodology when
we deliberately said, OK,
in this mode we are now entering
divergent thinking mode.
And whoever's facilitating
these design sprints,
we trained the facilitators
to embrace every idea
and to not judge
anything as they get
generated so that you
can kind of encourage
a lot of playfulness and a
lot of ideas being generated.
And then there's a deliberate
break in that design sprint
phase, where we say,
OK, now is the time
to prioritize and converge.
And so it's a way of sneaking
in these different modes
of thinking without calling on
like anything that might seem
eerie [INAUDIBLE] or whatever.
And so as facilitators,
like anyone
who's facilitating
designs for brainstorms,
kind of has some ability
to kind of facilitate that
by saying like, OK,
let's just take a moment
to be with ourselves as we go
into this phase of the design
brainstorm, for example.
AUDIENCE: You're always
making it analytical.
IRENE AU: I know, because I'm
speaking to this audience.
Speaking to this audience, yeah.
But that's the culture
that we're in, yeah.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
What kind of meditation do you
practice regularly, and then
do you have any advice for
when you kind of get to a point
where you plateau a little bit
in meditation and mindfulness?
IRENE AU: That's interesting.
I never thought of
the word "plateau"
to describe my own
practice, because I
don't think of it in terms of
like trying to get anywhere
or trying to measure it or
evaluate it in some ways.
It's really about
taking a few moments
to just sit and be with myself
in a mode where I'm not judging
or processing or
reacting to anything.
And in terms of
what forms, I mean,
really what I think
about it, I have
been practicing this for much
longer than I even recognized.
I started journaling
when I was nine years old
and continued that regularly
up until a few years ago.
And so that's a
form of meditation
in a way as a
mindfulness practice.
I practiced
meditation off and on.
But honestly, it really
did not resonate with me
until just a few years ago
when I combined it with yoga.
So for a long time
for me personally,
sitting alone and
just being with myself
was really, really hard to do.
And so I just directed
a lot of that energy
into physical energy.
So a lot of the
exercise that I do
becomes meditative
in its own way,
because I'm training
my mind to-- I
engage in really highly
choreographed, high intensity
cardio stuff.
So that choreography
requires me to stay focused.
Otherwise, if I go off thinking
about work or something,
then I'll mess up and I won't
get the routine or whatever.
So that's one way that
I use to train my mind.
And then I also just
sit with myself.
And even if it's in a moment
where I just don't have time
to deliberately sit and om, just
taking a few mindful breaths
is sometimes all it takes
to re-center myself.
So I don't really think
of in terms of plateauing.
It's a way of coming
back to center.
Does that make sense?
Anything else?
OK, well thank you so much
for you coming and sharing.
And feel free to contact me
if you have any other thoughts
or questions.
I really appreciate
your attention.
[APPLAUSE]